Continuity in ​Avengers: Endgame​ could
get confusing... even if you were in charge
of decorating the sets.
A sharp-eyed fan has pointed out an inconsistency
when the Avengers travel back to 2012 — one
you're only likely to notice if you have every
detail of ​The Avengers​ committed to
memory.
In case you need a quick refresher: Endgame's
second act sees different teams of Avengers
traveling to different periods in the past,
in an attempt to snatch all six Infinity Stones
before the Mad Titan Thanos can get his hands
on them.
Tony Stark, Steve Rogers, Scott Lang, and
Bruce Banner are tasked with returning to
2012 and the Battle of New York, where they
know three can be found: the Time Stone, the
Mind Stone, and the Space Stone.
Banner is able to convince the Ancient One
to pony up the Time Stone, but grabbing the
other two proves to be a great deal trickier.
After a brawl in Stark Tower, Loki is initially
secured, and both the Space Stone and the
Mind Stone is in the custody of the Avengers.
But as they and a bunch of S.H.I.E.L.D. agents
start heading down the elevator to drop Loki
off to the authorities, it becomes apparent
that one of the heroes will have to take
the stairs.
"Woah!"
"What do you think?  Maximum occupancy has been reached."
"Take the stairs!"
"Stop Stop!"
What we'd like to call your attention to is
the interior of that elevator, because when
the time-traveling Avengers take a ride in
it, it looks a little bit different than it
did the first time we saw it.
Here's the Stark Tower elevator as we saw
it in 2012's The Avengers.
Meanwhile, here is the same elevator, with
all of our heroes aboard, in Avengers: Endgame.
We never realized that one of the lesser-known
effects of time travel involved slight changes
to the decor of your target destination.
You'll notice that the rest of the set dressing
is spot on.
The interior of the elevator, though, is plainly
not even in the ballpark.
We know what you're thinking: the hardworking
folks behind Avengers: Endgame's set design
deserve a break here.
After all, they were tawsked not only with
giving a distinct look and feel to a film
that would become the biggest of all time,
but also with painstakingly replicating sets
from previous movies, ones which they almost
certainly didn't even work on.
How could they possibly have been expected
to nail every last little detail?
Well, realistically, they couldn't have.
But there's a flip side to that argument:
obviously, The Avengers was used as a reference
when staging this scene.
If it hadn't been, the rest of the decor in
the shot wouldn't have matched up.
It's highly unlikely that that table, those
lamps, and that sculpture had been sitting
in a closet somewhere on Disney's lot since
The Avengers completed filming, just waiting
to be dragged out and used in another scene.
No, those props almost certainly had to be
recreated for Endgame — and if that detail
of the old Stark Tower set was subject to
scrutiny when the flick's crew was building
the sets for the Battle of New York scenes,
then all of them were.
So, what's up with the elevator?
Did they think nobody would ever notice?
"Thought we wouldn't notice.
But we did."
We'd like to propose an in-universe explanation.
What if the Avengers didn't travel back to
their Battle of New York, but an ever-so-slightly
different, alternate Battle of New York?
It could even be that the aesthetic of Tony
Stark's elevator was literally the only difference
between the two timelines.
We like this explanation, because maintaining
continuity with the entire rest of the Marvel
Cinematic Universe on Endgame must have been
the ultimate logistical nightmare.
It definitely couldn't have been a snap to
bring everything back from previous films.
There are probably a million other tiny errors
like this just waiting to be discovered, and
we just explained every last one of them in
one fell swoop.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about the Marvel
Cinematic Universe are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.